una escena caótica en la frontera entre
belarús y polonia cientos de emigrantes
intentaron cruzar rompiendo las barreras
pero otra barrera humana los esperaba
del otro lado con la amenaza de las
bajas temperaturas todos ellos intentan
llegar a polonia territorio europeo a
través de la frontera con belarús
son personas inocentes que quieren un
futuro mejor para sus hijos muchos de
ellos no tienen comida ni agua tienen
niños pequeños y está haciendo mucho
frío el clima está helado
por su parte varsovia acusa a minsk de
alentar a los migrantes de medio oriente
y áfrica a cruzar la frontera como una
forma de guerra híbrida en represalia
por las sanciones de occidente contra el
gobierno del presidente alexander
lukashenko por sus políticas represivas
pero el mandatario niega que haya creado
una crisis migratoria y culpa al bloque
europeo por los cruces y el trato a los
migrantes en lugar de intentar
comprender la situación en curso e
invitar a defensores de los derechos
humanos a consultas las fuerzas de
seguridad polacas ejercieron presión
psicológica sobre los migrantes
desplegando equipos y aviación y
utilizando gases lacrimógenos en
respuesta al uso injustificado de estos
métodos una parte de los migrantes
comenzó a destruir las barreras polacas
polonia letonia y lituania vecinos de
belarús han declarado el estado de
emergencia en los últimos meses debido
al dramático aumento de la inmigración
irregular